في شهر اكتوبر الماضي اعلن عن ولاده شركه
اكسال الفرنسيه هذه الشركه جاءت نتيجه
اندماج بين الشركتين مختصتين في تصنيع
الروبوتات والانظمه المسيره
[موسيقى]
شركه اي سي اي وكذلك شركه اي اكس بلو
اعلنت عن توحيد قدرات الشركتين في مؤسسه
هذه المؤسسه تضم اليوم 1500 عامل ومهندس
وتقني كما يتوقع ايضا ان لا تقل ارباح
الثانويه عن 150 مليون دولار فما اهداف
هذا الاندماج وكذلك كيف سي ينعكس على خطط
التصنيع داخل الشركه هذا ما سنتعرف عليه
مع رئيس التنفيذي لشركه اكسيل الحاليه
السيده ففيان نابوليتانو اولا همم مستر
همم اهلا بك معنا في عسكريتاريا ما هي
اهداف هذا الاندماج وكذلك ما هي تاثيراته
على خطط التصنيع لديكم في المستقبل
ارجوكم
اندماج بين شركتين معرفتين في مجال
الروبوتكس هما اي اكس بلو والثانيه هي
ايكا وكلتهما من الشركات رائدات في مجال
الروبوتكس وخاصه في المجال البحري على مدى
20 عاما ونحن نلاحظ ان هذا المجال يتقدم
بسرعه كبيره لذلك قررنا ان نمضي يقود من
ونؤسس شركه جديده اسمها اكسيل لتوفر
الابتكارات الحديثه لعملائنا وتزودهم
بقدرات اضافيه لحل المشكلات ونرى انه عبر
اكسيل سنتمكن من تعزيز القدرات والامكانات
التي تتمتع بها الشركه همم المسافه بين
بعض منتجاتكم لديها استخدامات مزدوجه هل
على الجانب الاخر تعتقدون ان لديكم فرصه
في قطاع المسيارات البحريه الصغيره
اوكي السوق
تعمل في القطاعين المدني والدفاع ونرى
التطور السريعه يحدث على المستويين
العسكري والمدني في مجال تطوير الانظمه
المسيره لكننا نود ان يعمل العملاء على
رفع وتيره برامجهم التي يمكن ان تعمل دون
ضروره وجود نظام جي بي اس للاستدلال على
مواقع هذه المسايرات ونحن نعتبر هذه فرصه
كبيره لنا لتنمو واعمالنا في المجال
الدفاعيه والاستراتيجيه التي نعتمدها من
اجل ذلك هي اقامه علاقات شراكه لتعاوني مع
العملاء اضافه الى السعيين لتعاون مع
الشركات رائده في المجال او الذهاب مباشره
للتعاون مع الجيوش والقوات العسكريه في
الدول في ما يتعلق بالذكاء الاصطناعي
الكثير من الشركات التي تصنع او تعمل الان
على تصنيع منظومات مسيره او روبوتات يلجا
الى الذكاء الاصطناعي اين انتم من هذه
الاستخدامات والى اين وصلتم في هذه النقطه
تحديدا
من تطبيقات الذكاء الاصطناعي ونتمتع
بكوننا واحده من الشركات القليله في
العالم التي تتمتع بهذه القدرات خاصه
المنظومات البحريه فهناك شركات اخرى توفر
تطبيقات لمجالات مختلفه الا ان المختصين
بالمنظمات البحريه قله قليله نحن نستخدم
الذكاء الاصطناعي لهدفين رئيسيين اولهما
ضمان سلامه العمليات مثل الملاحه بسلامه
وتجنب الاصطدامات والالتزام بقواعد
الملاحه هذا احد جوانب دمج الذكاء
الاصطناعي اما المجال الاخر فهو تعزيز
قدرات المهام فالمسيرات التي نملكها قادره
على تغيير مهمتها تلقائيا فور اشعاري
وجودي جسم غريب في قاع البحر على سبيل
المثال عندها تقوم المسيره بتغيير مهمتها
لدينا هذه الامكانات هو القدرات التي نرى
انها مهمه جدا للمستقبل لذلك نواصل
استثمار في هذا المجال مصطفى بيان فيما
يتعلق يعني بعد ما اتممتم هذه العمليه من
الاندماج هل لديكم خطه للتوسع في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط خاصه بانه هذه المنطقه تحتضن
الكثير من الشركات الكبرى العامله في هذا
المجال الان
في الشرق الاوسط ولديناه هنا الكثير من
العملاء وعملائنا دائما يطالبون والدينا
برامج جوري الاقمار الصناعيه كما نتعاون
كثيرا مع القوات البريه في السعوديه ومصر
والبحرين وغيرها من الدول كما نعمل على
برامج تطبيقات المحليه والمجال الذي انه
يعد الانشطه فيه هو المجال البحري حيث
نتعاون مع جميع القوات البحريه في المنطقه
حيث كنا مؤخرا نقدم خدماتنا للبحريه
السعوديه فنحن موجودون فعليا في المنطقه
ولدين الكثير من الشركات كما ننوي توسعه
هذه الشركات فيما يتعلق بنقله التكنولوجيا
نحن نعتبر هذه المساله بالطبع مساله حساسه
لاننا شركه تكنولوجيه والتكنولوجيا قيمتها
عاليه جدا لذلك نقوم باختيار شركائنا بحذر
لكننا قادرون على الانجاز ولدينا مثال جيد
حليا وهو شراكه مع البحريه البلجيكيه اذ
لدينا برامج معهم ومعه هولندا كذلك في
اطار التعاون التكنولوجي ونمل ان نحضر في
المستقبل بمثل هذه الفرصه للتعاونيه في
الشرق الاوسط
مصر فابيان نابوليتان ورئيس التنفيذي
لشركه اكس ال الفرنسيه شكرا جزيلا على كل
هذه التوضيحات